sparkling out of play we're fine Edwards
turns it over to the basket crank knock
by smart behind
this is defensive hustle he not tell you
Marcus is just what are those guys did
giving up on nothing here you go
[Applause]
watch waters too green that's it
native no tip now
[Applause]
[Music]
with the finish on a Captain William
Boone and Kevin Walker to the fitzlee of
Boston suspect
Kemba Walker going into his bag it's a
Time Lord
throws time for one second and pounces
on Julius Randle
[Applause]
all right here we go smart looking
looking for Tatum gets it in Tatum takes
[Applause]
a lot of fun no question look at this
shot I mean no space to work
the game at 3 was a - but look at JC
tail wastes no time at all
blood cast in his first year at Kansas
and we had to be good friends that's the
best coach green Holies with the blood
is green surgery we don't know any of
that stuff but absolutely rolling oh my
lord throwing it down good play by smart
and good read by Time Lord throw it up
throw it up time door rises up freezes
time and throws it down and opposed to
tell you the Marcus Aldridge will have
one point I was flirting so shot no shot
keV Oh throw it down young fella throw
it down I'm bored strikes again in San
Antonio good pass temple Walker and
enjoy Kimmel Walker throws it up in time
lore want to keep getting major minutes
tonight javante green for a baseline
lobs it over this is something else
gonna look there's the plane throw it up
look at this oh wow
I'll be looking look at that
Tatom drives gorge right there Tatum
gets a while take some Tatum ties the
game
the inbounder is grant Williams who they
trust late-game so Marcus smart just
hands-off I I wouldn't mind seeing that
again like they're making that live it
looks to me initially like their feet
get tangled that's exactly what happened
to me Paul Falls because their feet get
tangled
[Music]
[Applause]
nice and way she's difficult Rex often
throws away could pass by Marcus smart
Wanamaker
Italy
for the flush
[Applause]
on the ket and look at him to spring up
dump on whoever wants the challenge here
at the rim soul athletics so bouncy
good-hearted it's going to hurt your
that's gonna hurt your percentage a
little bit when you start looking at
your defensive numbers Boston has its
largest lead
[Applause]
and look at this just great leading the
break taking socks are paying for it all
the link basically what are you doing
get out of the way whose baby is that
someone get that baby out the street
great finish by jaylen Brown look at
that head at the rim lam trying to go
back to turn stripped
oh no he's fast the whole at the 50 fast
way to look like off the transition
there's Kimmel Walker drivin dumps it
lay and Jalen Brown with a 360 Jam that
fast break brought to you by FiOS by
Verizon one - what do you make of what
they've done since that time well I
thought the demand early on in this
[Applause]
guy's a legit star players Brad Stevens
not afraid
26 points in their choice to have offers
Detroit turnovers Walker
oh nice this is I live down a 44 percent
shooter two or three blocks
[Music]
[Applause]
great pass the tea turned his head lost
where the ball was debunkers
[Music]
fine I'll just go back into the end in
the first quarter this is what turned it
around right here for the Celtics smart
for three Walker little dance man goes
by
whoo big shots by the Celtics at the end
of the first and second court inside
smart goes it down with authority look
at Marcus smart in the post goes quick
baseline and canter let's sit up front
don't have a foul to give watch out to
the three
their defense Mike look it Daniel theis
moving his feet there's the space this
long outstretched arms now here's where
it gets a little crazy 9 of 12 you see
they're very efficient sounds come up
with a steel watch out yes guys I brute
virtue bought that green in transition
this to see magical moments like that he
said I never thought I would ever have
my own signature shoe but if you work
hard yourself wildest dreams can come
true in that colorway he's got on the
black iridescent Paul let's see the
officials talking with each other away
with the rebound and spark comes across
sparked into the lane wide outside to
where he wants left hand huh what a
beautiful pass and that's what the white
power will make you do get very creative
and invent a move because this is how
you attack a shot blocker hello welcome
back we know you've been hurt looks like
you got some rest
jamie rahn
and that green to a basket for to back
that up that's awesome
[Applause]
my collects green and gray just finishes
it off watch them slide by
misleads my tat off to get the shot away
[Music]
the reason he was laying up the cordage
giveaways down
picked up Walker took off for the hoop
and got to when you trying to lay it
down does so - very cool man at the rim
by theis think that with Grant was it
grant either vote ant Williams on this
play comes over vertical get that give
it the full sis at the office goes up
get it out of here mark hill both inch
apart a green with the elevation to
double pump and throw it down with your
right hand look up down and who's
interesting you've been looking at the
numbers they have only one win on the
road against them over 500 team Jason
Taylor bring that slow then this is just
a great bull by BGI yeah I'm my shoulder
the rotating man would not get there in
time and I'm going strong
I'm gonna use my for moochers it's low
pass throw at a turnover that's their 15
turnovers where we tell you
[Applause]
[Music]
he just thought that he got hit at the
other end now this is just a great move
by Brown to the basket we've seen the
explosion of Tanith brown and once they
get the load of fats first field goal
the Boston lead is down to two Tate
about the drive is Marcus smart smart
coming off there's behind them under six
Michael Holly and Tommy have the
halftime show next Celtics Oh Beasley
tried to attack the rim theis metal wait
step behind does it matter
recovery blocks the duck at the rim they
cannot inbounds the ball just call the
timeout move the pen Tatum hit the rim
on the Miss intentionally loose Paul
Brown for the tie
[Applause]
here teeny
[Applause]
that just like you say all teams do it
differently now let's go down all Harden
almost had them this is a great pressure
shot by Brown that was a terrific shot
under that situation his second
three-pointer of the ballgame and the
most important shot for the Celtics who
had suddenly gone cold in the final
quarter now you see how hardness that
rebound
see that's the guy who was supposed to
cut off the I'd be surprised at this
level of shooting last that a steal
Brown will take it in jumper from levert
comes up short Allen with the board and
a reload offensive plays you'll see this
is a guard going up and meeting Jared
Allen at the rim tremendous flight there
you might think he shooting every time
he touched it Vance picks it off ahead
to Sexton drives to the basket great
Rock